[Music]
joe biden facing increased backlash over
his border policies including limits on
ice when it comes to actually arresting
illegal
immigrants now three republican senators
including our next guest are pushing
back with a new bill aiming to allow
police to enforce immigration laws
alabama senator tommy tuberville is here
to explain
welcome and good morning to you senator
tell us what's going on
well not a lot of common sense to be
honest with you especially in washington
dc and
you know this empowering law enforcement
act that i've put forward basically
you know they've cut the legs out of ice
uh their apprehensions are down
almost 70 percent this year with the
influx of migrants coming in
you know that's ridiculous so this
basically says we want to empower the
local and state law enforcement which
right now they don't have jurisdiction
but give them the authority
to work with ice to do what they need to
do
to apprehend and extend the 180-day
period right now if we catch somebody
from a murder from rape
from child molestation something like
that we cannot
hold them past 180 days and that's
ridiculous after 180 days
we have to turn them back into free
people which is
going to be back into the united states
not outside this country
which only makes other law enforcement
agencies job all the more difficult and
all the more dangerous
senator we also want to ask you about an
op-ed you recently wrote in the wall
street journal the
the headline is pretty jarring it says
i'll keep
veterans pensions safe from communism
what do you mean by that senator well at
this time last year president trump and
larry kudlow
who was working with president trump at
the time sent a letter to the secretary
of
labor saying listen uh we're not going
to empire
uh china with investing 700 billion
dollars of the military's pension plan
and uh citizens that work for the
government 700 billion they were going
to invest in china
businesses now china's businesses they
don't play by the rules
they they commit corporate espionage
they violate
u.s sanctions and they don't they don't
comply with basic audit
and regulatory standards and we do not
want to
uh empower the military of china they're
our
adversary they're our enemy and they're
growing every day it is ridiculous
that we would put any pension fund money
into china
we need to make sure that we send a
clear message
of zero tolerance towards chinese
aggression and if we don't do that
then we're going to be way behind the
game when it comes to keeping up with
their economy
and their military all right senator
tommy tubberville two bills coming
forward this week
see how those progress wish you the best
luck thank you so much
thank you still ahead